so the Vivo X90 Pro Plus is already a
ridiculous phone it's got a red faux
leather back it's got 12 gigs of RAM it
has incredible cameras 80 watt charging
it's 1100 bucks oh that is great but the
best thing about this phone to me by a
mile is actually this fingerprint reader
so we've seen a lot of under display
fingerprint readers for the past couple
years roughly all they're in the same
size you know small and in the bottom
middle of the phone but this ultrasonic
sensor is gigantic and works kind of
like magic so I'd say it's around twice
the size of the ones we're used to
seeing and it's also super precise so
instead of having to tap your finger you
know 10 to 15 times to set it up you can
register a new fingerprint here in just
one firm tap that's it so from that
point unlocking your phone anywhere on
that huge surface is ridiculously fast
to the point where you basically never
even have to see your lock screen again
if you don't want to and then on top of
all that you can do dual fingerprint
authentication for your most secure
secret files whatever those are so one
thumb by itself doesn't work the other
thumb by itself doesn't work but scan
them both at the same time and it goes
through so sick